we have will clemente joining us will
how are you buddy
i'm good brother how are you i'm doing
fantastic today's an exciting day
bitcoin hitting 45 000. i saw you
tweeting up a storm all kinds of
different thoughts how are you feeling
about sentiment in uh on twitter and
kind of in the market in general
i'm good you know it's it's pretty mixed
um you know i feel like some people are
still kind of in disbelief but you do
have a few people in the timeline who
are kind of euphoric so
it seems like a a good kind of mix here
i mean general
vibe does kind of feel like disbelief
though
hey but uh what bears have to remember
is that you could be bearish at certain
points and you may make a little bit of
money but ultimately you're picking up
pennies in front of the steam rule this
is a decades-long trend and we only
going up and so there's when the battle
bowls when the war facts
like
you should be on a plaque somewhere for
saying that that's a great uh great
thing all right talk to us about some of
these charts you got first is you've got
the uh this price chart you've got a
whole bunch of different levels uh green
and red that are outlined here what is
this showing us
yeah as you just said these are
basically just price levels i drew out
i think the
the kind of main point i wanted to just
get across here was just saying that i
think at this point
we're kind of right below major
resistance and so from like a short-term
kind of trading perspective
uh i don't think the rr here being you
know the gig along is great until we
clear that resistance
um you know you never want to buy right
below resistance you never want to sell
you know right before we hit major
support and so just from that
perspective um as we're kind of pressing
up against that major resistance
um you know if i was a short-term
trigger and i wasn't already long i
would kind of just you know wait out to
see what the reaction here is at this
level but nonetheless again we're
approaching this you know major
resistance level both kind of in this
consolidation pattern that we've been in
as well as just you know horizontal
price structure uh going back over the
last year or so which is right around 46
47 k
that's also around the yearly open
there's a few different moving averages
over there as well
but that's kind of a you know as i feel
like we've been talking about for
several weeks or whatever
um that's kind of a key level that i've
been watching
and then another kind of
i have two other ways you can look at
confluence with this in addition to
everything i just said
the first one is the next chart which is
short term holder cost basis
so we talked about this last week so i
don't want to like repeat myself too
much
but essentially this is the aggregated
cost basis of all market participants
that have been in the market for less
than 155 days or less than five months
um
and right now this kind of aggregated
cost basis sits at 46
hundred
it does kind of move around a bit you
know week to week whenever we speak but
generally it's been hanging out around
46 to 47 k uh as of today it's sitting
at forty six thousand two hundred
and then last kind of thing that i
wanted to point out for on the
confluence of 46 to 47k being kind of an
important level
is the third chart the third chart is
looking at basically a heat map of all
the bids and asks
across different venues in particular
in this chart we're looking at biffonex
the reason we're looking at bitfinex
biffinx has a higher hit rate than
most of the other venues
if not they have the highest hit rate
kind of back testing looking at all of
the kind of you know quote unquote walls
that they set on the both bid and ask
side
um
generally speaking you know biff and x
tends to kind of be the the you know
smart money in a sense and whenever they
kind of you know place either a buy or
sell wall that tends to have some
dictation on on future price movement
uh and so what we see currently is that
they had just actually in the last hour
or so kind of set this ask wall
between 45 and 48 k so that's confluence
as well um you're seeing some some you
know large asks step in from from
different x in particular um what you
don't want to see
is like a partial fill
so
this seems kind of counter-intuitive um
like what you want to see for bowls in
this scenario because we're talking
about an ask wall you want to actually
see it fully get filled see all their
orders get filled and conversely if it
was a bid wall what bears would want to
see is you know full fill of the bid
wall the reason is because like the
market basically moves
in two ways it moves because of you know
effort and absorption
so effort being active orders they're
stepping in right so when you just go on
you know whatever venue you're using to
allocate the bitcoin you just market buy
right you're buying at the the market
price it's like if you go on ebay right
and you hit and you hit buy it now right
you're willing to maybe pay a little bit
higher of a premium just to go ahead and
get the exposure and lock in your your
purchase right uh and then there's limit
orders and limit orders are essentially
saying i like to use this ebay analogy
because i think it i think it makes
someone of sense um you know you go on
ebay
something's listed for fifty dollars you
don't wanna pay fifty dollars you say
well i don't deem that fair value for
this item but i'll step in and place a
bid at you know forty bucks if it fills
great you know that's where i i think
this is you know worth my you know
purchasing power
if not then that's cool you know it
didn't reach what i think is fair value
it's the same thing in the order book
for bitcoin right and so people come in
and they set limit orders uh both on the
bid and ask side
um and so whenever you see you know a
clump of bids or asks or wall
whenever you see that fully fill
that means that the effort in the market
is is you know outweighing the
absorption
so in this case if we see this ask wall
get fully filled to me what that's
indicating is that the effort or the
active orders uh is outpacing the amount
of absorption or the
this wall of tasks that we're looking at
now or limit orders that we're looking
at now
so that's what i would be looking at you
know kind of the bearish scenario would
be these bids fill like 60 70 and then
price reverses because at that point
it's it's showing you that the amount of
effort in the market couldn't outpace
the amount of absorption that was set
out if that makes sense um but yeah
aside from everything i just said
specifically talking about the order
books across the board looking at order
books on-chain and technical analysis
all three are showing that the kind of
4647k area is an important level for btc
um and so when you talk about kind of
you know this other framework that we've
been talking about it's kind of there's
value buyers and momentum buyers right
and so i think for a lot of those kind
of momentum market participants or trend
following strategies a lot of those will
kind of trigger if we can get above that
area
so when you start to look at this it's
obvious that that area is really really
important right in the spot market i saw
you tweeting this morning about the open
interest just violently spiking upwards
uh and we've got the chart here for that
as well
first explain like when we see these
massive movements up in open interest
what is that telling us is happening and
then how do you evaluate this in
comparison to some of the spot stuff
you're just talking about
sure so open interest is just telling
you the number of contracts that are
open
um so that's where open interest by
definition selling is telling you how
much futures you know how many how much
interest is there from the futures
market you know and being active in
bitcoin um
and so you know a lot of times like when
i post this people will automatically
think that when i'm saying open interest
is up that it's bearish it's not
necessarily the case i mean
most of the times that we've spiked up
into the zone in the chart has been
bearish
um but all it's tell all open interest
rising is telling you is that there's a
large amount of
of contracts coming into the market
right and so that could be aggressive
longs or shorts um so with that being
said again all this is telling you is
that there's a large amount of or build
up of contracts in the system but we
need to look at other things to kind of
you know give us hints as to the
aggression of the positioning because
there's always a long for every short
sorry cody's deciding to to eat my chair
um there's always a long for every short
it's all about kind of gauging what's
the aggression of the market
participants on both sides of the
contract right so the example that i
always like to use is for example you
know you have one contract you could
have like a you know degenerate on the
long side that just wants leverage long
exposure but on the short side of that
that contract you could have a market
maker who's taking the short side of the
contract but they might be you know
delta hedged and by being long spot so
they're you know long spot and then
they're they're short the the perp
contract so you know it's it's all about
kind of gauging what's the risk profile
of um all the different market
participants that are making up that
open interest and we can look at the two
charts after this to kind of uh to kind
of gauge that positioning
not only can we do that but we can also
look at in real time um aside from kind
of you know the what i just said we're
going to look at the next two charts
that's kind of
somewhat of
a predictive approach as to kind of
trying to gauge the open interest the
other thing we can do is look at you
know how is the open interest behaving
and that can kind of in real time give
us more clues so what do i mean by this
like if you know as we talked about 46k
really important price level if if if
price starts to you know wick above that
and you know open interest is kind of
you know just flat or increasing and you
don't see any kind of wipe out in open
interest
then that probably is indicating to you
that a lot of that buildup hasn't been
aggressive shorts
right and and um you know conversely if
we start pushing above that price level
you start to see oi kind of you know
spike down on on pushes up that's that's
showing you that you know shorts are
getting forced to close um above that
price level so
i would say you know you can look at the
next two charts that we're about to look
at the other thing you can simply do
um is just you know sit out for a second
wait see how is open interest reacting
with the price level uh and then kind of
you know gauge your your thesis from
from there um but with that we'll look
at from a more predictive standpoint um
two charts to kind of gauge
uh in a predictive sense what what do we
think that you know how do we think that
open interest is this position so first
we'll look at um the spot go ahead my
bad no it's gonna say the spot premium
explain what's going on here with this
first of the two charts
yeah so on the bottom you'll see
perpetual's basis
this is comparing the aggregated spot
price versus the aggregated per price
um and so whenever the indicator is
green so you'll see whenever it like
flips negative that's just telling you
that the
spot is trading at a premium to perps i
mean conversely whenever it's gray or
whenever it's positive
that's showing you that perps are
trading at a premium to spot or in other
words spot is trading at a discount to
perps
and so we've been in a pretty prolonged
regime of spot premium um over three
months now which i'd have to go back and
double check on this but i'm like 90
confident this is one of the longest uh
spot premium regimes that we've ever
seen in bitcoin's trading history
so that's that's one thing the second
thing is is the chart after that which
is the annualized rolling basis the
three-month basis or in other words
you know quarter lease which i've been
calling it in the newsletter
um
you know essentially this is uh the
difference between the current spot
price and the three month futures
contract so you can buy spot um and you
can sell the future capture the
difference when the market's in contango
um so what i did here was i took that
basis
and then i adjusted it for inflation so
for cpi inflation of course you know if
we want to get really nuanced i don't
think cpi is the proper
gauge of inflation but nonetheless
adjusting for cpi inflation uh the you
know three month basis is currently in
backwardation
um and so it's currently at like
negative two point five percent or
negative i know it's negative two point
something and some change
i posted it last night the exact decimal
point if you want to check uh it's just
shy of negative 3
but this current regime of of
negative basis lasted 65 days
compared to the 35-day regime that we
saw uh during last summer
and so to me this combined with
the regime of spot premium that we've
been in is showing to me overall that
we've just kind of got this healthy kind
of derivatives greed reset quarter if
you will um
and you know in general you're kind of
seeing a lot of that exuberance that's
kind of cooled off from the from the
derivatives market
so when you start to think about this it
feels like uh we're watching a lot of
the i'll call more kind of macro uh data
points point towards bitcoin uh we were
joking earlier that uh everyone in the
mainstream media seems like why is
bitcoin not going up it you know their
geopolitical instability inflation it's
like well like bitcoin's up you know
about 30 or so since russia invaded
ukraine and it just feels like the
volatility sometimes masks these types
of moves but then if we start to look at
the on-chain underlying metrics and i
know you've got a couple of these charts
it feels like uh i think you said last
week like there is this laying out of a
scenario where once a catalyst happens
it will ignite based on this illiquidity
in the uh supply is that kind of still
how you're thinking about this
yeah exactly um you know the way lynn
alden's put it is basically you know
we've got the fuel laid out but we need
the spark right and and so the the two
charts that we're about to look at are
kind of
visualizing that
the first one is the long-term holder
accumulation ratio this was created by
uh checkmate who's the lead uh analyst
at glasnode as well as david puel from
um arcade best
we had david on the the podcast this
week so i'm looking forward to to that
episode dropping but
this this metric essentially compares
the um rate of growth
in long-term holder supply to the rate
of increase in bitcoin supply issuance
and so whenever this you know whenever
this metric is is significantly trending
down whenever it's below zero uh it's
showing you that the amount of long-term
holder accumulation is outpacing bitcoin
supply issue and so in other words it's
got this deflationary aspect to it
because more supply is getting locked up
than is coming into into circulation uh
and so currently by that measure uh
bitcoin supply based off of this
specific measure is currently at the
most deflationary um level that it's
ever been in its trading history uh so
in other words it's showing you the
long-term holders are locking up a
supply at a pace that's you know
outpacing uh bitcoin's issuance to an
extent that's never occurred before in
the bitcoin market
yeah it's uh it's incredible to see this
man it feels like we're just seeing this
all play out all over again from the
summer of 2021. when we look at the
illiquid supply shock uh we can
literally see uh that that is what was
happening i'll talk through this a
little bit
yeah so uh very similar to summer except
this divergence is uh now i double
checked after we talked about it last
week it's now you know confirmed it's
the largest uh divergence that we've
seen
from this specific measure
in bitcoin's history uh this is the
specific metric i created uh back
at the beginning of last summer and like
may or june of last summer it's
comparing the amount of supply held by
illiquid entities who are entities who
sell less than 25 of the coins they take
in to highly liquid in liquid entities
so in other words it's a ratio of weak
to strong hands whenever the ratio is
ticking up that means supply is moving
towards entities who sell less than 25
of the coins that they take in
uh at the same time this also adjusts
for the increasing amount of
supply so one of the questions that i
would often get about a liquid supply
before i created the ratio was well you
know isn't this naturally going to go up
as some supply comes into circulation
but this metric actually adjusts for
that because it's telling you uh the
relative amount compared to
highly liquid and liquid supply so it's
telling you at all times no matter how
much supply there is what's the relative
holdings between those two cohorts
and so as you just mentioned
seeing this tick up over the last two
weeks is obviously a good sign but in
general we've just seen this massive
divergence over the last two months two
three months really uh of supply
continually
um you're getting locked up by these
entities who have a low historical
tendency to sell
conversely to you know what people will
often like refute about like exchange
balances dropping right the argument
there is always well you know exchange
balances are going down but people can
just move the coins right back to
exchanges in you know 10 minutes
and technically yes that's true um but
with a liquid supply it's literally
telling you
the historical tendency for every
on-chain entity to sell their coins it
looks at you know based off of
heuristics on my wallet you know what
what what's the amount of you know btc
that i'm taking in and selling and so
you know by definition um
you know
aside from like what that argument is
about about exchange balances this is
literally telling you the likelihood of
those coins coming back onto the market
right and so
in confluence with long-term holder
supply this again is showing you just
that supply is getting locked up
and i also think it's really interesting
to note kind of the difference between
now and late 2018
in 2018 i mean illiquid supply dropping
pretty much marked 2017 top and
continued to decline all the way through
into the bottom of the bear market
and so
um you know that's that's another kind
of
you know difference between between now
and then
and kind of the underlying supply
dynamics from from an unchanged
perspective
what about whales what are they doing
yeah so the next chart we're looking at
the um essentially what i did was i took
all the large
whale balances quote unquote it's all
the entities who have over a thousand
btc and then i filtered out all kind of
the known on-chain entities that glass
node and specific heuristics track so
you know gbtc the purpose etf
um all the otc um desks that glasnow
tracks
some of these different entities that
they you know have heuristics on um and
you know have actually labeled
and so then you know you filter that out
and you get what i you know call quote
filter you know filtered whale balances
and that's that green line as you can
see whales bought you know all the way
into you know the beginning of 2021 a
lot of that was you know the gbtc
arbitrage as well as the cash and carry
trade that drew a lot of capital in the
spot you saw whales holdings rise really
substantially then they distributed into
that whole kind of you know topping
period from end of you know february
into the beginning of may
they started re-accumulating at the
bottom of the summer we talked about
that here on the show i remember that
initial pop there at the end of july
like it was yesterday
um and then they started distributing
into the end of the year last year
um over the last like month or so you've
seen some like interesting behavior you
saw them kind of by the bottom at like
33 34k
distributed back into this consolidation
and then over the last week or so you
start to see their holdings tick up a
bit curious if any of that is is dokon
but um you've seen it we've seen their
holdings uptick a little bit over the
last few days but still when you zoom
out i mean we're still in a downtrend
from september of last year in terms of
their holdings
but conversely though what you do see is
that the smaller guys have been stacking
really aggressively and so that's that
orange line in specific i just pulled up
uh the entities with 1 to 10 btc
um and and so what you see is that you
know they're holdings over the last
month or two it's really just kind of
aggressively moved up um roughly
offsetting some of the selling that
we've seen from wales over that same
time period
um so obviously you'll note the
divergence between it seems like the
smaller guys have been buying from
looking on chain uh and the whales have
kind of been distributing over the last
month or two which is this kind of
interesting divergence which of course
isn't ideal right because um you know
generally speaking retail doesn't
outsmart large buyers but if we look
over summer um you'll see a very similar
kind of signature right because
the smaller guys were actually stacking
through all of summer they sold from
january 2021 all the way to may 2021 and
then they bought from the bottom in in
may 2021
all the way until the end of the year um
and they actually front ran all the
whale spine at the end of july and so
you can see that they're like kind of
smack dab in the middle of the chart uh
during the summer range of last year so
it's just something to to keep in mind
although ideally what we do want to see
is starting to see some of those you
know the whale balances start to tick up
substantially again and kind of break us
out of this downtrend in their holdings
that we've been in since last
september all right now
i got one question for you then joe's
gonna answer some questions do quan says
he's gonna buy 10 billion dollars with
the bitcoin he's got three billion in
dry powder and he's starting to buy he's
buying 100 million or so a day
uh it seems
how much of the recent you know i don't
know 10 12 increase in price is just him
buying versus other things
yeah it's an interesting question right
because
the way he's kind of bought is he's like
basically told the whole market that
he's gonna buy um and i tweeted like a
week or two ago i was like are we just
gonna ignore the fact that doecon's
about to buy like a billion dollars plus
with btc and then everyone's like no
it's priced in and of course over the
last week it wasn't priced in um
but yeah i think like the question is
how much you know
a how much of the how much of the price
increase has solely just been people
front running him
right and and you know people knowing
that there's just a steady you know bid
and steady 2 up over the last week right
and then the second question is
will he be able to initiate momentum in
the market
and so what i mean by that is i think
sailor for example at the end of 2020 i
think he played a large role in kind of
initiating
um some of that momentum not only just
because of you know the corporate
treasury announcement which in itself
was was you know
you know good for bitcoin's narrative as
kind of that whole you know the
inflation hedge narrative that really
propelled us into the end of 2020 um but
solely just from a supply demand
aspect because
he took a large portion of supply off
the market
locked up a large portion of you know
supply um and so in my opinion that kind
of initiated or helped initiate some of
that momentum um as you know not only
you have people front running you but
you know you're steadily kind of placing
this bit into the market that's that's
you know helping it drive higher so i'm
curious you know will will his you know
bid that is it you know he's not
finished yet uh will that be able to
push us over
some of these kind of momentum
thresholds trigger some of these you
know um trend following you know market
participants you know momentum stuff um
will he be able to trigger that or will
we just see as soon as he's done buying
you know will we just come right back
down right are people just saying all
right you know i'm just gonna step out
of his way let him finish his bias and
then we'll just you know continue on
down um we'll see i mean we have you
know the way i would approach that
question would just be to say set some
definitive levels where you're looking
at momentum to get reclaimed we've
talked about some of those things at the
beginning
um and then just you know look at this
in kind of an if-then format if it
reclaims okay then i guess he did
initiate some of that momentum if not
then no so that's kind of the way i'm
i'm seeing it i'm curious if
um we'll see that kind of follow through
once he's done
i think
can we look at this i just wanna for 10
seconds i just want to show this one
last chart i think it's i think it's
interesting for people to note um just
real quick it's the uh the last one it's
it's the u.s trading hours so i think
this is interesting for people to know
because
when you look at throughout bitcoin's
history
you know asia has really dominated the
market correct um and you know you saw
that even into like the end of 2020 into
kind of early 2021
but since since the end of may you know
we're talking about like the different
types of buyers we just talked about
kind of the size of the buyers and i
can't that whole kind of
talk about the kind of the spending
history when we're talking about where
the buyers coming from it's really
interesting to see us trading hours when
you compare them to other you know
trading sessions and trading hours and
the price premium during those trading
hours we've seen over the last year or
so it's 10 months as as of today the u.s
trading hours have traded at a premium
and that's kind of increasingly
happening so i think that's
i just want to say real quick that i
think that's interesting that you know
you're starting to see some increasing
interest uh in bitcoin from the united
states during u.s trading hours it's
super super interesting and i think that
this is the type of stuff that uh
won
kudos to you for you know seeing a lot
of this stuff but also too uh i think
this is the intellectual curiosity that
people have is you can start to
understand kind of how this stuff is
playing out and it's ever changing right
it's not like the stock market that's
been around forever and there's not that
much changing joe what questions you got
yeah i was going to actually ask about
that because i saw your tweet this
morning and i thought that was
interesting uh my other question though
would be around some of the stuff we've
seen in the news i i feel like we've
talked about this before but i'd love to
just get a better understanding about
how you think about uh some of these
large corporations and entities buying
bitcoin and how you tell that from the
data right so we've seen not necessarily
buying maybe but blackrock right they've
been in the news that they are very
interested in serving their clients with
bitcoin uh goldman sachs i think he
posted on twitter the the front page of
their website which was very funny but
how do you think about it from an
on-chain perspective are there specific
things that you look at you say hey this
is what needs to change to realize that
some of these big players are actually
in the game now
well i think like the obvious thing
would just be looking at whales balances
right and if you start to see those you
know large buyers not only in their
holdings but also the number of whales
stepping in
um you know that's what we saw at the
end of 2020 we saw like unprecedented
growth and number of whales as well as
their holdings so that would be kind of
the biggest telltale sign um the other
kind of you know thought experiment i've
gone through with with what you just
kind of described is
when we have these entities coming in
are they looking to
you know
actively allocate to liquid tokens all
that obviously bitcoin being the main
thing but you know whether you like
other coins or not i mean these these
you know traditional finance people are
interested in defy and all these
different kinds of things
i'm curious will you see kind of liquid
token investing or are they solely just
looking to get involved with kind of
infrastructure around the asset class
right basically kind of the you know
when there's a when there's a uh was it
gold rush you wanna you wanna be selling
shovels right and so like will we see
goldman for example um you know will
they just be looking to get involved
with building out like otc desks or like
execution arms and infrastructure for
large clients and will they focus on
that or will they actually do some kind
of you know liquid token and dusting um
that that's the question that i don't
really have an answer to um i've asked
some of my buddies who are have you know
a little bit of like tradify background
they seem to kind of lean towards
they're probably just more interested in
getting involved in the infrastructure
around the asset class but i guess
well well the only way to really tell is
i guess with time but from an on-chain
perspective to like fully answer your
question um it would just be some not
the whale stuff that i described would
be kind of the obvious thing you liked
goldman sachs website
yeah i thought it was cool um you know i
thought i thought it was cool to see the
the space you know get attention um
didn't mention bitcoin though it's just
uh kind of you know the whole digital
asset metaverse
that's kind of what it seemed like they
were they're interested in but you know
everybody's
got to start somewhere get them get them
down the funnel right so i like it i
like it well when you think about um
what we're watching play out here
if dokuan is successful in backing uh
ust with bitcoin do you think we could
see a bunch of other stable coins and
maybe even central banks kind of follow
the playbook and that just is like a
multi-year you know buy uh
trend that they have to buy the bitcoin
in order to back their uh their assets
sure so
first of all i really liked your
interview with uh dokkan i took on a i
took cody on a walk this morning
and um i was listening to it uh when it
was like two hours ago actually so
i like the last question you asked which
is basically like along the same premise
of what you just said and his answer was
yes uh and and i i kind of agree with
him in that he's he's basically kind of
setting the playbook for
um you know other protocols and just
other entities in general to back
currencies with bitcoin as a reserve
asset um although bitcoiners you know
don't love luna as you know being
another you know blockchain right um at
the same time you know i think
bitcoiners aren't you know fully
appreciating the kind of gravity of
in real time we're seeing a currency
albeit maybe not the one that they would
love to see
um we're seeing a currency being backed
with bitcoin
as you know the pristine collateral that
it is uh and so i think it personally
it's a genius move by dokwan um and i do
think that over time
um you know once once bitcoin's
liquidity grows you know you can't back
the us dollar with bitcoin quite yet um
but you know i think over time you'll
you'll see more currencies um be at
least partially
uh backed by bitcoin maybe over time we
start to see something like a part gold
you know park bitcoin backing at first
or peg i should say at first and then
maybe over time that pivots to solely
bitcoin we'll see but i do think this is
uh kind of a you know an interesting
um
you know
it's kind of zero to one event in terms
of of currencies being back with btc
very similar to kind of like you know
the the sailor
immaculate conception of corporate
treasury announcements um you know i
think
or or the el salvador you know nation
state adoption i think this is up there
with with
those types of events in terms of
significance for
uh bitcoin's adoption moving forward
i completely agree i think uh
there's a lot of reasons why people may
not like it but
i actually think this is incredibly
bullish and uh i mean after having
talked to him like he's a bitcoiner
right he he understands he he gets
exactly why bitcoin is valuable pristine
collateral et cetera so it's pretty cool
so uh before we look at he's not
competing with bitcoin he sees it as
additives and that's i think correct you
know although i don't
like full disclosure i don't own any
luna but you know i think
some of the bitcoin people maybe should
you know realize like you know
they like dokwan sees bitcoin in the
same lens they do and and you know he's
trying to um make it an additive thing
because he understands the value
proposition of bitcoin as that pristine
collateral in the same way that they did
so
correct
um before we let you go uh tell us about
the uh the podcast and uh in the
interview coming out
oh sure thanks for the plug um i'm
having on yacine alemandra and david
well from arkandest this week on the pod
so
it should be out tomorrow sometime
tomorrow
um we talk about all things on-chain
derivatives
they're doing some cool stuff they've
got a lot of research
uh coming out new cool stuff and they've
got a couple metrics that they created
so we kind of ran through that including
the uh the long-term holder accumulation
ratio that we talked about
earlier in the in this conversation so
should be a should be a fun one but um
if if you're interested uh hop over on
block where intelligence that's our
that's our youtube channel so
awesome man all right well everyone
feels better when uh when it's green not
red seems like price is going up at the
most basic level so we'll keep watching
and we'll talk again next week but i
appreciate you coming on
all right brother you guys have a good
weekend thanks again by the way he's at
5.99 he's almost at 600k oh well it's
getting close yeah let's go push him
over the edge there you know
maybe if joe tweets once and everyone's
ever going to go follow you
that'd be the smart thing to do if you
want some free alpha go go uh go follow
will
all right buddy sounds good see you
later see you well i see you guys